[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que j'ai vu un truc sur micani je
voulais le faire et je voulais le
montrer au téléspectateur il ya un
nouveau jeu par un carton c'est que je
lance comme ça des balles de ping pong
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et il rentre au stand
attention à la limitation vitesse aussi
y a rien de vrai là rien de prêt et je
le redis la suspension avant des faca
sait rien des prières veulent des
mécaniciens mon casque et qui n'ont rien
à faire là c'est ta question venue
et je pense que le travail est abîmée au
la bbc
surtout qu'ils s'en aillent
faudrait savoir si la suspension est
touché ou pas il repart après un arrêt
interminable 50 secondes 3
d'immobilisation il va direct assez
cet argent métal et payet encore mais
des baisses dans ta vie jean mi mât des
paillettes dans ta vie non
[Musique]
m
il est contre la ville et jours fériés
vous aviez fait mais après c'est l'homme
mais sinon tu peux faire c'est m
essayez avec des patients voire le
relooking déjà que tu nous as fait
isabelle morini bosc et raymond isabelle
morini bosc à raymond c'était ça
regardez c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]